quand je dessinais sarkozy il était
tellement facile regardez on fait deux
yeux comme ça voilà on fait une année
comme ça voilà et on fait une petite
langue parce qu'il a dit côté gniark
gniark comme ça ça fasse vrai - et puis
on faire la règle le holà comme ça il a
des oreilles comme ça un peu de sport
qui est bon et puis est ce qui explique
très curieux avec lui c'est que je
rajouter deux pieds comme ça et le
dessin était fini alors eh bien eh ben à
l'époque il y avait un gars qui était au
conseil d'administration qui s'appelait
à la menthe et trouvait que c'était
scandaleux d'ailleurs même sarkozy
violet parce que je dessinais une petite
mouche
voilà or au dessus de même cette fois
plusieurs couches pendant des semaines
j'ai dessiné trois bouches au dessus de
la tête de loties continue toujours à
téléphoner envoyer des motards comme ça
il y avait une led genre j'aime beaucoup
vos dessins toutefois si vous pouviez
enlever les mouches bon et puis après je
sais pas qu'est ce qui m'a pris j'en ai
fait 15 et rédacteur en chef me
téléphone il me dit mme enfants l'avait
dit roy quand même